Raymond Ibrahim is a best-selling
author, historian, and Middle East
analyst specializing in Islam, Jihad
ideology, and Christian persecution.
>> The first Crusade, again, the big lie
nobody tells you is right before it was
a really new iteration, was the Seljuk
Turks, and what they were doing to
Christians was horrific.
A former US Library of Congress scholar
fluent in Arabic, he's written multiple
best-selling books and hundreds of
articles examining the theological and
historical foundations of Islamist
movements. And on today's episode, we
will cover the doctrinal roots of Jihad,
This is an open-ended command. It says,
"Fight the polytheists wherever you find
them. Lay in wait, ambush them, kill
them, take them as slaves."
>> The historical continuity between
ancient conquest and modern terrorist
movements, what's really destabilizing
Europe, not just mass migration, but
ideological migration. What parallel
societies are forming, why have
assimilation collapsed, and why are
governments pretending none of this is a
concern. We're also going to unpack why
countries like the United Arab Emirates
and Saudi Arabia officially classified
the Muslim Brotherhood as a terrorist
organization, while the United States
and United Kingdom don't. Raymond
Ibrahim is here to explain how we got
here and where this road leads. Well,
first of all, thank you so much for
being here. Welcome to the show. Thanks,
Jillian. Very happy to be with you.
Uh I've seen a lot of your podcasts
recently, and I got to be honest, it's
it's
shaking me up quite a bit. So,
off the top, I just want to jump right
in here. I have a lot of questions.
And I want to start with this one. So,
when you're translating these original
Jihadist texts from the Quran,
what's the most disturbing thing you've
read that you think the vast majority of
Westerners have absolutely no idea
about?
Yeah, that's a great question because um
I come from that academic background
where we were now I see it as
indoctrinated into believing Islam is
this wonderful religion of peace etc.
etc. And then I was working at the
Library of Congress and with all these
you know texts coming from the Islamic
world and so forth and long story short
this actually is related to my first
book which was the Al-Qaeda reader. I
came across writings by Al-Qaeda in
Arabic that had never been translated
and they were just laying around in the
Library of Congress cuz the Library of
Congress has all these books from all
around the world just laying around in
bins.
And yeah, yeah. And I started reading
them. I was at Georgetown University so
I was very much involved in that field.
Right. And I had believed what everyone
was telling us which is this you know
what what what Al-Qaeda had said is
we're attacking you cuz you attacked us.
It was a grievance narrative, okay? You
>> everyone saw the freaking
Bin Laden letter on Tik Tok like oh the
great Satan has done this to our people.
You haven't you know let's not forget
like yeah that's the narrative of the
evil imperialist West.
>> And it made sense in the context of what
I had been learning in college and in
what he was saying and what Western news
media was kind of confirming what he was
saying. So that the shock for me was
then to go and read the Arabic texts and
just to give you a little more context
right before that I was finishing my
master's degree and I had written it
about the first pivotal battle between
Islam and the West. This is before 9/11.
It actually came out right around 9/11,
okay? And so I was immersed in a
historical thing and I knew there was
this jihad and conquest going on but I
too had assumed yeah this is kind of
like you know this is the modern world.
It's not really happening anymore.
Forgive me when you say that the first
clash between radical Islam and the West
what timeline then are you talking about
if it's pre 9/11? Oh well well hopefully
we can get into that the the actual
history. So the first major clash which
I wrote about was my master's thesis
with Victor Davis Hanson. I know you had
him on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So what
was with him? This is back in the late
'90s. Oh my god.
>> And
and I was just making you you know, to
be a history major, you want to make
uses of languages and I knew Arabic and
I was I was studying classical Greek.
So, I looked at the Byzantine and and
Islamic nexus in the 7th century
and I started writing about that first
major battle, the Battle of Yarmouk,
which became my thesis, okay? And
that had jihad, okay? And then we but I
had but now I'm learning about this guy
bin Laden, he did 9/11 and he's telling
us it's because of what you do and the
Western media supporting him. Okay, so
that's the backdrop. Then I get all
these Arabic texts written by Ayman
al-Zawahiri, who's the who became
actually the leader after bin Laden was
killed and he was the number two man at
the time and also by Osama bin Laden.
And when I read him, these are now
written to Arabs and Muslims in Arabic.
Westerners are not supposed to be privy
to this.
It was it was Are you familiar with the
ISIS approach, which is no, we hate you
because you're an infidel. Yes, of
course.
>> what they said Al-Qaeda. They said, no,
no, no, this is a religious thing. Yeah,
we're telling them it's about grievances
and and we're trying to demoralize them
and we're trying to make use of the
useful idiots amongst them, but no, we
hate them on principle. This is what the
Quran teaches. We have to do jihad,
etc., etc. So, I think that was the
first not so much of a It wasn't a
shocker cuz I've always known Islam does
teach that. It was a shocker kind of to
see how much deception was going on both
by Al-Qaeda and being enabled by the
West.
Okay, this is taqiyya, this deception?
>> one of the Yeah, this is the broadest
term that is sort of used for it and um
it it it it's so The problem is, you
know, it's not just taqiyya. There's a
lot of different forms of deception and
just deception in general. Muhammad in a
canonical hadith or saying said, "War is
deceit."
And guess what? The infidel, you're
always at war with him one way or the
other. So, that's almost like a blanket
statement that you can always deceive
the infidel, okay? And there's so many
intricate doctrines that allow
deception. One is called taqiyya. And
you know what this is? So, it's
legitimate for a Muslim to do this.
Let's say um let's say you ask me you
want to borrow um $20. Okay. And I say I
don't have a dime in my pocket. Now,
you're going to assume I have no money.
But, if I have a $20 bill and I don't
have a dime in my pocket, I didn't lie
to you.
>> [laughter]
>> And I see this all the time, okay? Uh
where Muslims will speak It's It's like
a double kind of speak, and you as the
non-Muslim who's who's not familiar with
the context will think they're saying
something kind of peaceful, but it
actually to Muslims it's messaging
something different.
Okay.
Before we get into the history of this,
it's it's important to establish and I
try to establish
this element every time I engage in
conversations about radical Islam. You
got billions of Muslims, and the vast
majority are lovely people. In fact,
I believe you yourself I have Muslim
friends. Everybody tells me I have
incredible Muslim friends that comes on
and talks to me about radical Islam.
Every single person. It could be Gad
Saad, it could be Brigitte Gabriel, it
could be Dr. Nazarian. Every single
person who has escaped the Middle East
and ran from radical Islam is like, "I
have incredible Muslim friends."
So, Yeah, we have to iron this out, so
forth.
>> Okay, so explain to me
I I appreciate that we're going to get
into the history of Muhammad, Islam, the
Quran,
the the jihad verses and all of that,
but
why then are like I don't know, 1.8
billion Muslims
awesome, Mhm. and then
a couple hundred million are not. What
is the difference? It's the same book,
same religion. Yeah. Okay, so
>> [laughter]
>> I mean, we can we can spend the rest of
this talking about this.
>> actually answer it for me. I've I've
asked now pretty much everyone. No one
can tell me that. No one I've asked.
Muslims, I've everyone I've asked
everyone. No one actually has that
answer though. Like, well,
you know, they just you know, they're
good people they do I've heard
everything from, well, those Muslims
don't read the Quran. I'm like, well,
that seems unlikely. Well, those Muslims
are just good people and and like they
kind of ignore those verses just like
Christians ignore parts of the Old
Testament. You know, we all do that. And
I'm like, yeah, but all Christians
ignore the parts of the Old Testament.
So, we're still back to the thing of
like
>> I get it. Yeah, I know.
Allow me to elucidate. Please.
[laughter]
So, let me unpack this. So,
first thing you got to do is
differentiate between the religion and
the people. And I would I would argue
this is how you have to approach all
religions, okay? There's there's what a
religion teaches
and then there's what the people do,
okay?
Islam, and I've noticed you use the term
radical Islam, okay? There is no radical
Islam. Islam is Islam. The stuff that we
call radical is just part and parcel of
has always been. We call it radical
because it just we've somehow reached
this point where we think history has
ended and everyone thinks the way we do
and the natural culmination of all
civilizations to become like us. Just
provide them with enough material means
and you know, and everyone's going to
rise above it. Okay, that's sort of I
think Western arrogance, but
Islam is a coherent body of teachings.
It's very clear. It's very black and
white. It's not mysterious. I'm I'm
talking specifically of Sunni Islam,
which accounts for 90% of the Islamic
world, okay? It's it's a legalistic
religion. It's not mystical in any way,
shape, or form. According to Islam,
every action a human can engage in is
categorized as either forbidden,
disliked, meaning you you shouldn't do
it. It's not necessarily you're going to
go to hell for it, but neutral, okay,
whatever,
recommended, we'd like you to do it, but
you don't have to do it, and obligatory,
all right? Every single action in this
life. It's a very totalitarian system.
That's what Sharia is and if I forget,
we really need to talk about Sharia
because it's in the news and there's
some input I'd like to say about that.
But
now, if you look at the religion,
some of the stuff that we like to call
radical or try to present as aberrant
amongst Muslims is actually 100%
mainstream, all right? Um This can't be
possible. No, no. It well, it it is
possible, but we'll get into the with
the moderate.
>> go to Dubai and like I can
go out with my wife
>> we'll address we'll address that.
>> you go to Iran and someone's hair
showing and they get the crap beat out
of them. I cannot reconcile these two
Muslim worlds. Patience. Okay, boss.
[laughter] Okay. Okay, hold on. No,
because this is
because it this is a thorny issue.
Okay, so the religion, Sunni mainstream
Islam. Okay, for example, it allows
polygamy. That's not that's not open to
debate. Okay. The Quran talks about how
you can, you know, punish your wife by
beating her. Yes. Okay. Number two,
concubinage, right? Sex slaves. This is
in the Quran. Yeah. And it's important,
okay, real quick segway cuz you
mentioned, well, you know, the the
Bible, the Old Testament and
and they do that and Christians have
risen above it. Okay, here's the
difference. It's a very interesting
difference. I wrote about this like 20
years ago.
>> [snorts]
>> If you look at the old let's say let's
stick with the Old Testament cuz that's
what they talk about.
>> Yeah. Um Slavery
>> yeah, yeah, slavery, war, genocide,
Joshua, all that sort of thing
as it's presented. If you look at the
actual text, the way it's written, okay,
so God commands Joshua and, you know,
the Israelites or the Hebrews to go to
war and he mentions the names of the
people, the Jebusites, the Hivites,
that's the you know, and the Canaanites,
etc. etc. And the language is very
temporal. It's it's it's finite. It it's
not open-ended. It's it's almost in the
past tense, you know, they fought them
and that was it.
Now, if you go to the Quran, okay, and
guess what? Even though their enemies
were actually, identifiable personages
throughout history, the Persians, the
Zoroastrians, the Christian Byzantines,
and so forth, it doesn't use that word.
It uses
generally the word the kafir, which can
be translated as infidel or mushrik,
okay? Like there's a lot of words. And
the language is when you read the Quran,
it's in the present tense, okay? So,
fight the people of fight the kafir.
Fight the people of the book, Christians
and Jews. Fight. It's it's a constant
open-ended commandment. Whereas the Old
Testament, it's recording a historical
account. God said to them, fight that
group of people in that group of that
area at that point in time. So, it never
got codified into some sort of vision
for Jews or Christians that you have to
be a war with everyone.
The Quran's very different. The language
is is very transcendent and above and
beyond the finite moment. And so, it got
codified there that that's what Sharia
law is as a worldview. So, the most
standard thing in Islamic teaching is
you have two worlds. You have in Arabic,
it's called dar al-Islam, which can be
translated as the land or abode of
Islam. This is wherever Sharia controls,
right?
And then you have dar The rest of the
world is dar al-harb. Harb means war,
the land where we wage war until we
bring them into our land, okay?
>> of Islam. Yeah, and historically, people
don't understand this that they you
know, at least for the Muslim side, they
were at they were at such odds and at
war with the rest of the world that if
you were European, okay, and for
whatever reason there was a delegation
being sent to talk to a sultan, he had
to get an actual permit before he
entered the Islamic world because if he
didn't, he would get killed and enslaved
instantly because you are the de facto
enemy. That's how it was historically.
We haven't even gotten into the jihad
and what it did to the Western world,
okay? But Okay, I digress. So, Islam,
when you hear all this stuff about oh,
this is radical. This is not Jihad is
not radical. Jihad, and we'll get into
the history has been part and integral
to Islam. Always has been. Since
inception. Okay. And okay, the
attacks
attacks on free speech and
religious freedom. So for example,
attacks on the blasphemer, someone who
speaks against Muhammad and and that
which goes on all the time. Sure. Today.
Okay, that is completely part of Islam.
Always has been. Attacking and possibly
even killing the apostate who wants to
leave Islam. Complete Muhammad himself
is on record saying whoever leaves his
religion, kill him. Okay? So that's the
religion. Now,
does that mean what what is it almost 2
billion Muslims now? They all follow it?
And this is where the analogy that you
mentioned I agree with, which is yes,
look at
Christianity and Judaism and Buddhism
and Hinduism of course don't have these
sort of draconian world views, but it is
true that if you I look at Christians
and any other group, well a lot of them
don't follow any of their religion. So
to me what I'm trying to say is moderate
Muslims, and I don't care for that word,
and I don't care for the word radical
because radical Muslims are not radical.
What they are is observant,
pious Muslims, and what we call moderate
are lackadaisical Muslims. Uh you know,
easygoing, secular, cultural cultural
Muslims where yeah, you know, we we we
go we do the Ramadan thing, we we have a
feast, we go to the mosque once in a
while, that sort of thing. Some don't
even do any of that. So but in no way,
shape, or form do these moderate
Muslims, as we call them, who do exist,
they are not representative of Islam.
Okay? And that's the whole point. Same
thing you can say about like I said,
Christians and Jews and I mean look in
Judaism, you have the Orthodox Jews, you
have the secular or you know, reformed,
and obviously one will say one's not
doing it the right way, for example,
right? Yeah. So um
the the text, the teaching is what it
is. It is by any measure what we would
call radical and disturbing and
draconian. Um you know, the punishments
and the amputations and the whipping.
That's all part of Islam. Why? And um,
we if you want we can get into it but
because it's part of what's called
Sharia law. And Sharia law is based on
the literal words of the Quran which are
believed to be from Allah
and Muhammad's um, words and deeds which
are many. And um, and the Quran says you
have a perfect example in Muhammad and
you have to follow him, okay? And just
to show you what I'm talking about. In
the Quran for example, there's a whole
there's this doctrine which to me So you
were asking me earlier, you know, what's
what's the most problematic thing? One
was of course the shock at you know,
this disconnect between what what
Muslims were really up to with the
Al-Qaeda and what Westerners how like
not only were they clueless but they
were actually disseminating their lies.
But the other one was this doctrine that
even until now no one really wants to
talk about. People will talk about
Jihad. To me the most problematic
doctrine in Arabic it's called al-wala'
wal-bara'. And these two words can be
translated in various ways from they can
be called loyalty and enmity. They can
Some Muslims translate them as love and
hate which is actually pretty good. And
with this doctrine which is in the Quran
teaches Muslims can only be must only be
loyal to fellow Muslims, the ummah.
Yeah. Okay? They are their only friends.
And the non-Muslims you have to hate
them.
Okay? And it even says even if they're
your fathers and your brothers and your
wives. I translated a video of a popular
Egyptian cleric to my YouTube channel
who says
I've seen this. No, no. You've seen it?
I've seen it on your channel but please
tell the others. Yeah, yeah. Where he
basically says and this is this is
because of the teaching of the hatred
for non-Muslims. Islam allows Muslim men
to marry Christian women and Jews cuz
they're the people of the book.
But it's also interesting because of
course a Christian man can't marry a
Muslim woman. Why? Because of course
they see it from a purely patriarchal
worldview which is okay as long as it's
the as long as the woman is the infidel
who cares. She's subjugated. Anyway,
that's why you can't have a male
Christian or Jew married to a Muslim
because you can't have a Muslim being
subjugated, right? But so he says
even though that's a legit, you have to
hate her in your heart and show her your
hatred. And he says you can enjoy her
sexually, you can enjoy her whatever
way, you know, but you make sure she
knows you hate her.
Okay. And and and if and here here here
we go to the moderate thing. Even in the
audience cuz he's given a he's preaching
some Muslims are find it hard to
reconcile this. These are who we would
call moderates. But he says it's in the
Quran. It's and it is in the Quran,
okay? There's a Quran Sura 60 verse 4 um
says
Ibrahim, who's Abraham from Genesis, you
know, you know, Islam appropriates a lot
of these
biblical characters says so the Genesis
account God calls Abraham and he leaves
the land of Ur, okay?
And that's the end of it in the Islamic
account. Not only does he do that, but
he tells his former kinsman
un- until until you believe in God,
Allah, hatred will reign between us
forever. All right? And the Quran talks
about how these early pious Muslims
including the first caliph Abu Bakr and
Omar, the followers of Muhammad in wars
tried to kill their own relatives and
they did kill their own relatives. So
the whole point is loyalty belongs
exclusively to fellow Muslims. It's
What What Muhammad did as I always say,
the genius of Muhammad
is he took the tribal mores of his
world, 7th century Arabia, and
re-articulated them through a
theological paradigm which made them so
powerful. So now normal tribalism which
we understand is you know, me and my
people and you're the outsider, you're
the enemy. But now it's no longer my
race or culture, it's the ummah, it's
Islam working together as a body and
everyone's the other tribe and we're at
war with them one way or the other.
Okay, so that's Islam. Now going back to
the moderate thing.
Just because that's what the religion
teaches, okay? You have a whole host of
people. Remember, Muslims like most
people are born into the religion. It's
not like most people It's not like
Muslims automatically convert. I'm just
born into this. Yep. Depending on who I
am, the kind of person I am, you know,
either I won't A lot of Muslims honestly
don't even know a lot of this stuff and
the clerics try to hide it for them
because it will turn a lot A lot of them
don't know.
>> will tell me like and I have believed
this for quite some time. It was
actually Carl Higbie. I'm not sure if
you're familiar with him, Navy SEAL,
served in Iraq and Afghanistan and he's
read the Quran. And he was talking to me
about the Muslim Brotherhood being
banned from buying land in Texas and how
Arab countries like Saudi and UAE have
labeled this group a terror group but
the United States hasn't and the UK
hasn't. And I'm like, but the Quran is
so peaceful. It's the most peaceful
religion there is. Have you read the
Quran?
And I was like,
But just all my friends who are Muslim
have told me we're the most peaceful
religion. I just believed them. And then
all of a sudden I read parts of the
Quran
and I was
freaked out. Yeah. Freaked out.
Especially when you have the mayor of
New York
swearing in on the Quran. Because it's
one thing to be like, well, you're a
kid, you were born into the religion,
you know, you you you you're you're the
moderate guy, you're the good guy,
you're like all my Muslim friends. But
then you swear it on the Quran and I'm
going to presume you've read it.
And that's when I started to say like,
okay, hold on.
You've got Ilhan Omar. Mhm. She hates
America. She's clear about it. You've
got Omar Fateh who almost became I I
believe mayor of Minneapolis. Was it? Uh
or and but then he got caught in fraud,
he didn't make it. You've got Mamdani
who's now mayor of New York. You've got
the guy who's running I think Dearborn,
Michigan who's terrifying. And you're
seeing Rashida Tlaib. Yeah. Yes. And
you're seeing it now in the UK. No.
>> So
like like now you have all of these
different mayors who are Muslim
and they're they're only loyal to the
the ummah. Because you are a bigot and
you are a racist and you are an
Islamophobe. And although you live here,
I want you to know as mayor, you are not
welcome here.
And the day you move out of the city
will be the day that I launch a parade
celebrating the fact that you moved out
of the city because you are not somebody
who believes in coexistence.
Uh you're somebody who tries to preach
it uh but in fact you do everything uh
but that. So I I just want to put that
on the record. I know. And I'm just I'm
sitting back going, I I feel like we
need to be
really paying attention. And the
Islamophobe thing is quick to shut you
down.
>> I know. Well, it's that's what's that's
what it was created for.
But to really underscore the
the the swearing on the Quran. I mean,
people can't it's to me surreal if you
really understand what's going on. To
most people, oh, it's his religion and
why of course he can pick his Quran. Why
why does it have to be the Bible?
But what's really going on
okay, first of all, is and specially
this fellow, Mom Daughmi,
I forget the name of one of these famous
radical clerics that he said mentored
him or whatever.
>> Yes, I remember. I can't remember that
name either.
>> there's several of them who are have
said problematic things who are who are
you would call radical and who are
radical. But one of them said a very
interesting thing that most Americans
did not understand it they translated in
English, but I know translated in Arabic
what it is. And he was complaining about
America rules with man-made laws that
are other than Sharia. That phrase,
other than Sharia, in Arabic is actually
based on the Quran and it's it's anyone
who says that is basically the kind of
Muslim who hates democracy, hates
everything, and wants Sharia. This is
his mentor. So now think about this. The
guy who's swearing allegiance to the
Constitution is putting his hand on a
book that is dedicated to the overthrow
of any man-made laws and that teaches,
as I said, hatred for infidel, being
allied only with Muslims, that's full of
descriptions of beheading and crucifying
and torturing uh the infidel and he's
swearing on that to uphold the law to
protect the infidels. Okay? So uh let me
think And again, remember I was telling
about this concept of taqiyya where
there's a double kind of concept speak.
It's I'm sure when he has his hand on
that Quran, you know, on the one hand,
I'm showing you infidels, yeah, yeah,
I'm swearing to you guys. But I really
wonder what it is that he he's really
swearing in his mind. Right.
>> [laughter]
>> Right. That's That's when he swore on
the Quran
and I and I had some idea of what was in
there. Yeah. I was like, okay, now I'm
freaked out. And it was the uh
in addition,
at first I thought, why are we not
attacking his policies? We're getting
roped into the fact that he's Muslim
because
>> you know, then they could tell us like
we could we could, you know, distract
from how bad his policies are. And then
there's a rap song that he has where
he's
>> I didn't know he was a rapper till
recently. paying allegiance to the Holy
Land 5, I guess were the guys that went
to jail after 9/11
>> and sent funds to terror groups. And
you're like, wait, actually, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Hold on. So, so let's
>> And he has a picture flipping off
Christopher Columbus.
Right.
Which I get I mean, you know, this seems
mild, but think about what that means.
Like
the the civilization that I migrated to
and has elevated me to the mayorship or
mayorhood,
um I'm flipping it off without ever in
any way, shape or form acknowledging or
because they did bad things without
recognizing that my history and
heritage, Islam, has done a lot worse.
Right.
>> Okay. So, you know, all But then, you
know, to me, honestly, everything we're
saying is correct and and and and of
concern.
But to me, the greatest concern is that
we're so stupid that we let this sort of
thing happen without even thinking about
it. Okay?
>> We think about it. The problem are all
the young kids that want free buses and
have no idea, and to be honest, have
been told by all their Muslim friends,
probably like I have been for 30 years,
that it's the most peaceful religion.
That's it. So, you're like, yeah, and I
love my friends, so I believe it. Like
like
there were
Anyway, okay.
>> So, to give you an idea, you know why a
lot of this happens in America, by the
way? Remember I was telling you there's
two abodes, the land of Islam and the
land of which have to be at war. Many
people Okay, you see a lot of Muslims
flooding the West. Do you know that
according to according to Sharia,
Muslims are banned from voluntarily
going to live under
infidel authority? Why would you do
that? For the good life? That's not good
enough. So, the only caveat that allows
Muslims to go and migrate and still be
Muslims is if in one in in some form or
other, you're trying to help spread
Islam.
Okay? So, if I come and live amongst the
infidels and I do what I do what you're
describing, telling you all the Muslim
all the holy books is great, and I try
to convert you, or I try to help the
image Jihad has all these different
categories. It's not just physical.
There's Jihad of the tongue, which means
propaganda. Jihad of the pen, which
means also propaganda. Jihad of the
money, okay? And so they are in as long
as they're engaged in that kind of
Jihad. And Jihad of the womb,
demography. They encourage Muslims to go
have as many babies as you can in the
West. These are all forms of Jihad,
because Jihad means it's not necessarily
warfare. That's its primary
manifestation, but it means trying to
It's struggling to empower Islam in
against the land of the infidel. So,
any good Muslim who is in the West is to
some degree involved in this. That's how
he That's the only way they can justify
being in the West. If they could just
came here and are living under infidel
authority, because I want the good life,
that they're actually breaking Islamic
rules.
So, you're telling me Ilhan Omar is
breaking Islamic rules when she, you
know, was taken in as a refugee from
Somalia as a child.
>> Mhm.
And professes to be a fantastic
>> No, no, she's not breaking the rule as
long as in her heart she's I'm helping
Islam somehow. She clearly is, actually.
She makes that very clear. Um okay, so I
want to like let's go back to the
beginning. Here's my understanding of
this. It's like 600 AD.
>> Mhm.
Jews and Christians have been Christians
around for 600 years at this point. Jews
for I don't even know how many
>> Mhm.
thousands of years, how many millennia.
Uh
and all of a sudden there's Muhammad.
And he hears from the angel Gabriel.
Mhm.
Uh and Gabriel tells this guy like start
a new religion called Islam. Well, not a
new religion in the Islamic
understanding.
The Islamic understanding is Muhammad is
bringing back the correct religion,
which these Jews and Christians had, but
ruined it.
Okay, so the So, God had had That's why,
um you know, Abraham and Moses and Noah
and Jesus are prophets. Okay, so they
are, you know, they're they're part of
the the the the canon of religion, but
Jews and Christians ruined it by
rewriting scriptures. So, the Jewish
scriptures, the New Testament, are all
have been tampered with. Okay, so for
example, Muslims believe Jesus it's it's
it's amazing. They believe he was born
of a virgin and he performed miracles.
And he's going to come on Judgement Day.
But the fact but the idea that he died
and was that he was crucified or that
he's the son of God or that he was
resurrected, that's anathema to them.
Okay.
Why do those Why do Christians say that?
Because Christians lied and they rewrote
it. So, Muhammad's coming back to bring
to bring the world back to the original
untainted, unvarnished religion that
started all the way back with Abraham or
even Noah, okay, or even Adam and Eve.
They have Adam actually
and and that's so it's not a new
religion. It's he's bringing it back to
its pristine form. And just one final
thought since I'm talking about this cuz
it's related.
The idea you know, it's it's just Okay,
so Judaism, Christianity are obviously
interconnected organically. Okay.
>> Sure, because Jesus was a Jew.
>> Exactly. And then when he the people who
followed him became Christians.
>> Right. And I mean, obviously there's the
difference. But so for example, if you
look at the Bible, the Christian Bible,
what we call the Old Testament, the
Jewish scriptures, they are exactly as
the Hebrews wrote them. Okay, so
Christians didn't rewrite them. Right.
Now, what Muhammad did is he
appropriated all these guys, all these
historical figures from, you know,
from antiquity so he can validate his
new movement and say, "Yeah, I'm part of
this whole thing." But then he rewrote
everything about them. He didn't rewrite
it, but I mean, the Islamic narrative,
what he said and what came out in the
Quran and the Hadith led to a completely
recasting of all these characters. Okay.
So, for example, in I told you in the
end day Jesus comes back, which is
consistent with Christian eschatology.
>> Got it. But he comes back to break the
cross and kill all the pigs.
>> [laughter]
>> You know, to and to and to abrogate
jizya is a is a is a tax that Christians
and Jews are supposed to pay not to get
killed. And to abrogate that, which
means at this point now if you're a
Christian Jew, you either convert or
die. So that's the Islamic Jesus, Isa,
okay? And I already gave you an example
of Abraham, Ibrahim, who you know, he is
now used by Muslims to justify hating
non-Muslims. Because Ibrahim supposedly
in the Quran told his people, "We hate
you and there's nothing going to be
between us except war and hate until you
become Muslims." Okay? So So So
basically Muhammad took all of the all
all these he appropriated these
characters, recast them to validate
himself. And And that's why when people
say, you know, the Abrahamic religions
and they try to put Islam in, you know,
and actually it it it it makes it worse,
you know, because there is no bridge.
It's like I'll give you a final analogy.
Because for all these people, and I get
tired of it, the whole bridge thing and
Islam and oh, we share the same biblical
characters.
Here's what it's really like. Imagine
someone telling you, you know, let's say
you have a beloved grandfather who you
knew who knew you knew and you And then
I come out of nowhere and I tell you,
"Hey, that's my grandfather, too." Okay,
that sounds maybe I'm It sounds like I'm
ingratiating myself, but then I tell
you, "And everything you know about him
is wrong. It's It's what I know, okay?"
Now, is that going to create a bridge or
is that going to create a very great
conflict? All right, of course. I see
what you're saying.
So now the beginning, early Muhammad,
gets no traction. And he's in Mecca at
this point? Okay. And that's in Saudi
Arabia. Okay. And he he gets no traction
and I I believe he's And this is the
peaceful Muhammad. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, you want me to talk about that
dichotomy?
>> please cuz cuz then people will quote
those things, but it's my understanding
that that stuff that comes later
invalidates the stuff that came first.
Which is why when you were talking about
reading the Quran, you know, you know,
the scale falls from everyone's eyes. It
doesn't actually because if you
cherry-pick or if you're misguided and
people let you read certain verses, it
sounds very tolerant. Okay? So, the
issue is all right, Muhammad is he's
he's born in Mecca, he's from Mecca.
Born around 570 and he starts getting
the revelations
I think in in 610, right? He goes to a
cave and some
being comes out and starts choking him
and and almost and he starts sweating
and people you know, there's all
theories he's having an epileptic
seizure, but his wife Khadija tells him,
"No, no, that's the angel Gabriel."
Okay, so that's how it starts.
And so the Quran every verse you see is
supposedly Gabriel telling Muhammad to
recite Iqra Quran. That's where we get
the word.
Okay? So,
>> That's the word.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Recite. Yeah, Iqra which now means read,
but he was illiterate so Iqra in next
context is recite and that's what the
Quran means, you know, the recital. The
recital of Gabriel verbatim telling
Muhammad what Allah wants, okay?
That's what you're reading in the Quran,
supposedly. Okay. Okay? Now, um
>> [clears throat]
>> I just blanked out. What
What was I telling you? We were you were
you were telling me the history of how
he's peaceful
>> Oh, yeah, the the the the the the dual
thing. Okay. So, the
age. All right, so Mecca
Don't [laughter] say that to me.
I know it all too well. We're the same
age right now. I look fantastic. Editor,
no one's old here cuz we're the same
[laughter] fucking age. No, no, it's not
old, but it's All right, all right.
Older than I was. All right.
Okay, yeah, yeah. All right. So, I I
have these moments now where I'm like
deeply involved and then all of a sudden
I'm like, "What? What was I I know. I do
[laughter] the same. You go down a
rabbit hole and you're like, "Wait, hold
on. I started over here and I'm over
there."
>> passionate. Yeah, yeah. Okay, so the the
the Mecca thing. All right.
So, the Mecca verses, if you look at the
Mecca or the Okay, and all the verses
are revelations from angel as I said.
Now, the Mecca verses, if you look at
them I mean, you know, first of all, the
whole Quran is really it's in Arabic
it's it's poetry. And a lot of it just
is just vague, doesn't make sense. And
that's another problem because to if you
read it as a a translation especially,
that you're not even going to know
what's going on. But, amongst Muslims
there's a whole science about No, no,
this is this is what it the exegesis
which if you just if you're a casual
American or you know, English reader and
you you won't really know what's going
on. Okay, but anyway Don't they start to
do that with Christianity though? It was
an interpretation
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, of course,
everyone involved is involved in
exegesis, but that's what I mean. Even
in Christianity it's easy to read it and
say, "Oh, this is what it means." But,
then there's a whole school of thought I
understand. you know, by the jurist and
or you know, the theologians. So,
anyway, the early verses Yeah. Yeah, oh
my gosh. Okay. I This is where I It's
deeper than you thought.
>> [laughter]
>> Religion has been a struggle for me
because it's been so divisive amongst
humanity throughout you know, our
existence, but I
I I like I I I really try to understand
it because it means so much to so many
people. Jesus I can wrap my head around.
The teachings of Jesus, I'm like, I like
all this stuff. Like I can't get in I
don't know about the divinity stuff, but
like this whole, you know, love your
neighbor and don't be a scumbag. I mean,
I'm into that.
>> [laughter]
>> I like that a lot.
But, this this
the other this is particularly
disturbing. Jihad, okay. The Jihad stuff
is alarming. And then okay, so so here
we are on peaceful Muhammad now.
>> Peaceful Muhammad gets all these verses
which Muslims love to quote. And he
says, you know, you have your religion,
I have my religion. There's no coercion
in religion. And and also there's no
militancy in the Meccan verses, okay?
Why? Well, it just so happens that he
basically he was already he was an
orphan. He didn't come from, you know,
the higher noble class. It's the Quraysh
the that tribe was dominant and they're
pagans at the time, polytheist.
And he comes up with a monotheistic
message, okay? That's his whole thing.
And he gets, I don't know, 100 followers
in 10 years, all right? But he keeps
agitating and annoying these people, so
they eventually drive him out. And he
does what's called the Hijra. And if I
forgot, we need to talk about this cuz
Mamdani mentioned the Hijra, which is
migration. He migrates to Yathrib, which
we call now Medina, okay?
That city. Yeah. And we'll get into
that.
He goes now to Medina and now he becomes
a political leader, okay? He's he
basically gets elevated. It's actually
it has it's it's a lot of Jewish tribes,
a lot of pagan Arab tribes, and they all
coalesce and he becomes essentially
eventually a warlord.
And they start going on raids and he
starts winning. And with every win, he
gets more plunder and more followers
because that's the mentality. Hey, now
okay, now I believe God's with you
because hey, we're winning, okay?
It was that mentality still is actually.
It's I was going to say. Yeah, it still
is. And so as you know, as much as
Muhammad go gets stronger and he gets
more followers and then he and so now
the the Medina versus the revelations
are still going, you know, Gabriel's
still hanging out with him and telling
him what's going on. They become a lot
more militant, all right? And now
they're no longer sounding about oh, you
have your way and my have my way. It
becomes a lot more aggressive and a lot
more assertive, always consummate with
Muhammad's circumstances, which uh he's
getting stronger all this time.
And then a long story short, by so the
Hijra is in 622. This is when he's
kicked out of Mecca and he goes to
Medina. From 622 until 630, finally he
conquers almost the whole of Arabia and
Mecca, okay? He takes over Mecca. Which
was the kind of
>> hear of him like an Alexander the Great
or a Genghis Khan kind of a character.
No, no, yeah, I mean he because it's
still small scale. I mean this is just
Bedouin tribal warfare. It's not
massive, you know, Mongolian hordes in
that sense, but it's still bloodshed and
killing and decapitating and crucifying,
you know, but
to the Romans and Persians, this was
just, you know, like, okay, these
Bedouins are doing their thing down
there, okay, as usual.
So, they didn't take too much note of
it. Now,
Now, here's the thing.
If I just read the Quran,
>> [laughter]
>> I I
This is a bit of a sidebar, and I don't
want to take you too far off track, but
like
I'm kind of I'm of personally of the
belief that we're all the same. I think
we're all like whatever brings us to
life is the same energy. We're all
if there's a God, an expression of God.
All of this appears to me to be an
illusion, and I feel like if people just
took one giant amount of mushrooms,
they'd probably see [laughter]
that none of this is like But if you're
born into it, you know, this is the
thing. It's easy for you in your current
epistemology to say that. But if you are
this is all you've ever known, and
everyone around you thinks this way, and
everyone talks this way, then that
becomes the norm. And you're weird to
them. You know what I mean?
>> I'm exceptionally weird. I I'm
exceptionally weird. But but what I
struggle with so much on top of that
personal belief that I have
is knowing what we know now. So, if you
took me back a few thousand years ago,
and we didn't even understand, you know,
the fact that we live in a galaxy, let
alone a universe, let alone arguably
infinite universes, that
time and space are completely relative.
Like there could be multiple dimensions.
Like you're you're you're you're you're
effing around
on with Carl Sagan, you know, the pale
blue dot floating in this cosmic
monster-sized universe. Like we're This
is absurd.
And so now that we know this, though,
you know, I I can't understand why we're
still doing it. How are we not looking
back going, "Oh, I Okay, so they thought
that this was the center of the universe
here, Earth, and everything was about
us, and all of that. We're the center of
everything." Now that you know all of
this,
But do they?
A lot of them are
No, no, no. What Even here in the West,
people are now saying we have a flat
Earth. I mean, Very few.
>> I know, but my point is the
conspiratorial mind is such, and it's
really rife in the Islamic and and Arab
world, especially,
that anything the West says is often,
"Oh, yeah, they're liars." I'm not
saying they believe the Earth is flat.
I'm just saying um
Go to the college kids. Go to the kids
at Harvard. Go to the kids at Princeton,
at these Ivy League schools that are
being indoctrinated in this way.
Mom Donny was one of those kids.
So, they're surely getting an incredible
education on physics
I mean, math, astronomy, some They know
these things. At what point does do
these young, intelligent minds look at
this and say,
"Maybe he was schizophrenic. Oh, that's
that's a
That's a well-known theory. Yeah.
>> Oh, is it?
>> Oh, yeah. A lot of people That's They
think he was
Okay, the theories go from he was He had
epilepsy, from he was Gabriel was a
demon, he was demon possessed. This was
actually the go-to Christian explanation
of Muhammad.
And the you know, the epileptic, that's
later as people become more secularized
because he would fall and foam at the
mouth because which Yeah.
Yeah. But but it was understood by
Muslims, "Oh, yeah, because of the power
of the angels inside him, and he's about
to give us a revelation."
>> this poor guy's having a seizure. But
let me just finish the the two things.
I'm going to No, no, it's okay because
it's really important.
So, now he's powerful in Mecca, and all
these verses come out, and now it's
about warfare. So, you have a verse, for
example, it's known as the sword verse.
And it's one of the latest verses or a
revelations, okay?
And this one just is Remember we were
talking about the Old Testament uses
kind of finite language.
>> Yes. And this is an open-ended command.
It says, "Fight the polytheists wherever
you find them. Lay in wait, ambush them,
kill them, take them as slaves, okay?"
And another also sword verse 9:29, it's
the same chapter or sura, says, "Fight
the people of the book who up until
then, during the Meccan phases, the
people of the book were understood as
Christians and Jews,
>> Got it. were you know, there's a there's
some decent words towards them. And this
is what people again cherry-pick and
say, "Oh, he speaks well of Christians
and Jews, okay?"
But now the final verse is, "Fight those
people until they are subjugated and
they pay tribute, which is called jizya,
and you and feel themselves humbled,
okay?"
So, and now here's the thing.
If you look at the Quran, it's
What are we going to follow? I mean,
there's this verse that's saying peace,
there's this verse saying war. So, the
jurists, and this is there's complete
consensus about this, came up with this
idea of called it's abrogation, all
right? Which is in Arabic it's called an
naskh wal-mansukh, which means this
verse abrogates that verse. And the old
the new So, basically, long story short,
the newer verses, the final revelations,
abrogate all the old ones. And it just
so happens that the newest ones is when
Muhammad was at his pinnacle of his
career waging jihad on everyone, okay?
But
and now now we can come to here to to to
today's Now what Muslims do, so they
understand this, but they also use the
same exact paradigm, which is, "Okay, so
when I'm weak, I'm I can talk like the
Meccan verses because that's what
Muhammad did. But once I circumstances
change, I can do what Muhammad did,
which is now I can go on the offensive."
And I'll I'll I'll I'll end this with a
final little acute anecdote, which I
share often, from the Library of
Congress. I used when I used to work
there,
there were many Muslims. I used to work
in the African Middle Eastern division
with Arabic books and other books.
And there was a Muslim man there and we
were actually on friendly terms, you
know, we we we kind of respected each
other. He knew what I was about and I
knew what and he I know he was what you
would call radical, okay? Oh god.
>> But you wouldn't know it. I knew it
because I can I have an eye for that,
okay?
>> yeah. And we would talk often and
sometimes I'd in the cafeteria we would
debate Islam in a friendly debate. I
didn't know there was such a thing, by
the way.
Well, I want to get to that. Please get
Sorry, I won't take up I'll finish it
real quick, yeah. No, no, don't don't be
quick. Take as much time as you need.
Um so we're in the cafeteria and we're
talking. I'm telling him what I just
told you. I'm like cuz he's telling me,
"No, no, Islam's peace." And he quotes
the Meccan verses. So I'm like, "Yeah,
and what about the Medinan verses? And
aren't you aware that, you know, in as
much as Muhammad's circumstances
changed, so did his tactics, okay?" And
he's like, "No, no, no."
But I kept pushing it.
And finally, he just smiles at me and
goes, "What do you want? I'm in Mecca."
Because I'm in the United States and I'm
weak and I'm outnumbered. So of course
I'm I'm talking about the Meccan verses.
>> [laughter]
>> You understand the significance.
>> do. Yeah, okay? And I think there's a
lot of Muslims who think that way and
who will talk about the Meccan verses
because they are following the prophet
the prophet's example, which is when he
was weak. Yeah,
Islam is not suicidal, you know,
for all the draconian aura about Islam,
it's actually very pragmatic. And so you
as a Muslim polity
must wage war on your neighbor if
they're weak. If they're not and it's
not advantageous for you and you don't
have a good chance of winning, then
don't. Okay? So, you know, the the the
popular idea that we have of like all
jihadis are psychotic and just ready to
blow themselves up, which exists, of
course.
>> Oh yeah, that that that everyone says
they invite death. They love death. They
don't have our our western
>> dangerous ones are the majority who are
smart and bide their time and are are in
what's called creeping sharia and
Islamist machinations and who use the
system against the West and who cry
Islamophobia.
They're the ones who are really smart.
But the ones to me, ISIS, you know, I
always call them very refreshing because
for all their atrocities, at least they
really call it out, you know, they
actually So, Al-Qaeda was telling you
that I you know, was involved in this
massive dissembling campaign telling the
West grievances, but then telling
Muslims hate them. ISIS comes up, writes
an article and says, "Why we are
fighting you and why and the first thing
they say is because we hate you cuz
you're an infidel and has nothing to do
with what you've done to us." So, I find
that a little bit refreshing cuz they're
at least honest, but most Muslims are,
you know, a little more strategic than
that and they're engaged in that entire
panoply of strategies that I've
mentioned. Okay.
Why
does
the Why does Saudi Arabia say that these
groups who plan to take down the West
like the Muslim Brotherhood? I was just
talking to Brigitte Gabriel and she's
like, "Here's their 100-year plan."
It It's been It after 9/11 and and and
all of that like this was this is a a
DOJ document. It's written out and we're
35 years into it here in the United
States.
And you see it. You see it in the
schools. You see it in our policies.
You see it. Saudi sees it. The UAE is
now saying, "Yeah, we're not going to
send kids to go to school in the UK cuz
we don't want them to be radicalized."
>> Yeah. So, I'm like, well, hold on. So,
are you guys saying, "Yeah, this whole
umma thing,
you know, of just being loyal to all
Muslims"? They put the blockade on Qatar
because Qatar would not label the Muslim
Brotherhood a terror group. Uh
do they see it? Like are they going,
you know, "This part of the religion is
is a no-go anymore?" Are Do Muslims see
this? Do they see it?
>> why does Saudi label these groups as
terrorists? right. and and And then the
the United Kingdom is being brought to
its knees.
>> Yeah.
Huh? Okay. No, no, great great question.
And um
I'll explain it as this. And so, the
Muslim Brotherhood is actually born in
Egypt right around 1928.
And in its early manifestations, it
wasn't engaged in terrorism, but it
learned early on, you know, to play the
game and, you know, to to be uh more
involved in the sort of clandestine
civilizational creeping Sharia. Even in
even in Egypt, okay?
>> Okay. And um Egypt Think about it. It's
born in Egypt and it's banned in Egypt.
Okay, it's banned in Saudi Arabia. It's
banned in a lot of countries. Okay, so
these Muslim countries who pride
themselves on being Muslim are banning
this group for being a terrorist
organization, whereas the West is not
doing that and is letting them go in the
name of free you know, freedom and etc.
Now,
the reason the Muslim groups do it, it's
kind of
odd why. And
these Muslim regimes, the problem is
they're always kind of like, you know,
they're they're trying to skirt fine
line. On the one hand, they have to
present themselves as good pious Muslims
um to be accepted by their own people.
And on the other hand, you have groups
like the Muslim Brotherhood who are
trying to overthrow them because you're
not good enough of a Muslim. A lot of
the Al-Qaeda figures, for example, and
ISIS branched out of the Muslim
Brotherhood. They were originally Muslim
Brotherhood members, but they got tired
of the slow incremental game. And they
wanted some action. They wanted some
jihad, okay?
>> Al-Shabaab. ISIS and uh
>> That's but almost all of them are born
in from the Muslim Brotherhood. That's
the the the the grandfather organization
of all of them. Ayman al-Zawahiri who
became the Al-Qaeda leader a leader was
was a Muslim Brotherhood figure. Wow.
[sighs] Yeah. And uh
it's again
like I saw people are all excited in
France. There's some motion about kind
of outlawing the Muslim Brotherhood. And
I'm just thinking
now, you know,
Muslim countries are doing this and you
are not doing it, you know? Uh you don't
get it.
>> We haven't done it.
But I have to wonder
if part of the reason we have not done
that is because we're so deeply in bed
with Qatar.
You know, you got a half a
billion-dollar plane they just gave our
president. We've got our top air base
over there. So, on one hand, it's like
no, no, no, no, we're
we
Qatar, they're our allies. But it's
like, but not really, but kind of
really, but but not really. But they
house all these terrorists over there,
like leaders of Hamas and stuff. But
like, but no, they're good negotiators
on our behalf. But but not really, but
really.
But but but but then they spend 23
billion lobbying our politicians and
soft money on the kids at Harvard and
influencing their brains. But not
really. So, then part of me wonders, are
we not labeling
the Muslim Brotherhood a terror group in
America because of all Qatar's money? It
could well be because Qatar's definitely
a massive supporter of the Muslim
Brotherhood. Right.
>> Yeah.
That's got That's got to be. And if you
need them right now to negotiate peace
in Gaza, if you need them when Iran is
on the brink right now,
I guess I could see why if I was Trump,
I may be like, "Mm, I don't know that we
can make this move right now."
>> Realpolitik.
>> [laughter]
>> Like like if if if somebody if somebody
said that to me, if I'm president of the
United States, and I'm trying to expand
the Abraham Accords, and I'm I'm trying
I need Qatar to play ball, and I
understand the loyalty amongst Muslims
to despite the fact that Saudi and UAE,
Dubai are like, "Yeah, that group is a
no-go. Egypt, same thing."
But I need them to play ball, and they
support the Muslim Brotherhood, and
they're giving us, on top of it all,
this money,
I might be like, "Let's hold off on that
for a second until we get all this stuff
done. We can get it done later." I mean,
if you feel like it's for the greater
good,
but
I want I want to go back for just 1
second. You talked to me about how
Muhammad had
expanded and taken all over all of the
Arab world.
But
Jihad went on for 1,400 years bringing
us to now, right? And what's crazy is
all these these Pakistanis that they're
Muslim. Oh, the Indian they're Muslim.
Oh, the Somali guys they're Muslim. They
you go to I was in Tanzania it's called
Dar es Salaam when you land. I'm like,
okay, everything's in Arabic. It's
Muslim. Hold on. It it's
I mean, he was very successful.
It it's everywhere.
>> to talk about that. Yeah.
So, this is actually now this is what
I've always found fascinating this is
what I've always found most people don't
know about and this is this will answer
I think a lot of things because
>> Okay.
you know, all your questions which are
good and which I which I've asked
myself. The problem with them is a lot
of people try to answer it from okay,
let's look at the scriptures. Look at
let's look at the Quran. And we've done
that and I think that's legitimate. I do
that all the time, but the weakness in
that and how people use it is exactly as
you said, well, the Bible says that. The
Bible has violence. Why are you pinning
it on Muslims? Okay, so that's always
been the game.
>> That's the top.
>> Yeah, yeah. That's always been the game.
So, for me a long long time ago, I said,
okay, let's put the
scriptures aside. Let's see what really
happened. What did what did Muslims do?
Now, the narrative amongst and I because
I was in higher academia and I was
involved and I've read their books is
basically Islam in the medieval era was
this beacon of light and tolerance and
Europe was savage and
and the Crusades that started all the
problems. Okay.
So, let me give you a quick corrective
of what really happened which is the
antithesis of what you've been told,
right? So, Muhammad does his thing.
Muhammad dies in 632.
A lot of the Arabians try to break away
and then the first caliph which means
successor of Muhammad political leader.
Yeah, yeah. it. He he wages wars on the
apostates bringing them back in the
fold, okay? Apostates are the people
trying to leave.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
634, 2 years later, he dies and now you
have the first
the second caliph Omar. And this is the
the traditional opening of the Arab
conquests as they're known historically.
So,
now what does the world look like in the
7th century? And this is what most I
know Americans, maybe Westerners don't
get it. They always think of Africa
North Africa, Egypt, and Syria, and the
Middle East, and Morocco as
always having been, you know, if not
Islamic, Eastern and different.
They actually weren't. And that was the
heart of the Christian world in the 7th
century. If you looked at all of
Christendom, we always just think of
Europe, okay? Yeah, it was in Europe,
but the bulk of it, the older part of
it, the more important, sophisticated
part was what we call the Arab world
today. It was Egypt, it was greater
Syria, which encompassed, you know,
Lebanon, Israel,
Jordan, Iraq part. It was Asia Minor,
Turkey. And that's that's where, you
know, Paul sends most of his letters to
that place, okay? The This is where
Christianity was embedded. This is why
the first Roman emperor who became
Christian, Constantine, moved to the
East because that's where the Christian
world was, okay? So,
in one century after Muhammad's death,
632,
by 732, Muslims have conquered
If you look at the map, and other
historians have said this, literally
three quarters of the Christian world
through violent jihad. They've conquered
Egypt, which is one one of the most
profoundly Christian nations. They
conquered Syria, they conquered So, if
you go all throughout the West,
Libya, Tunisia, Morocco, Algeria. They
went into Spain in 711 and conquered
Spain. I give you the I give you the
year 732, one century after Muhammad,
because that's the year they're in the
middle of France. And that's the Battle
of Tours. It's a famous battle where
they're finally halted, okay? So, and
then there's a new iteration a few
centuries later, the Turks. Now, they
become Muslim, they become the standard
bearers of Jihad and and and they go and
now they conquer Constantinople, they
conquered the Balkans, Southeast Europe.
And
and
more than a millennium after Muhammad,
they're at Vienna in 1683. All right?
And so, if you really look at a map,
okay, Islam swallowed up most of
Christendom as it was known at the time
and they continued people don't realize
that there were so many European slaves
being being enslaved. Millions, yeah.
Not just them, they would go to Iceland.
As far as distant Iceland, they went and
would get slaves from there. They had a
little island called Lundy right off of
Britain and they would actually use it
to get slaves from England. And
according to conservative estimates in
just the 16th century, you had 1.25
1 and a quarter million European slaves
being sold. And and the conditions, I
mean, really are horrific because you're
because of that old hatred. It's not
just you're my slave, I have I have
contempt for you.
>> Right.
>> Okay? And America
So, to cap off this little historical
thing,
>> [sighs]
>> America's very first war as a nation
after independence is with Muslims
talking and thinking exactly the same
way. And let me just before I say that,
let me tell you this. What historians
don't tell you is what they do is they
drop the Islam thing and they'll say,
"Okay, the the Arabs, the Saracens, the
Moors, the Turks, the Seljuks, the
Ottomans, the Tatars." They'll never
talk about Islam. Okay, they'll just
give you these national iterations and
identities. And so, it from a secular
mind, it's like, "Okay, different groups
fighting different groups." Uh-huh. If
you do what I've done and especially in
one of my books, Sword and Scimitar,
this is where I talk about this deep
history and looked at the original
sources, all those Muslim groups, the
the national groups, the Turks and
Arabs, they identified themselves first
and foremost as Muslims, and they
rationalized why they were waging war
because it was jihad, and we are
commanded to do this, all right? So,
when you hear someone saying, "Oh, ISIS
is you know is hijacking Islam." No. We
have 14 centuries of records telling us
that's exactly how ISIS is is basically
emulating the early Muslims to a T. So,
when you see all the graphic stuff they
do and the hateful speech, that's
actually what the historical record
relays for 14 centuries. And so, going
back to America to cap it off,
their very first war war after
independence is with those Muslims who
are saying the same thing. So, what what
happened is they started after America
broke away from Britain, Britain was
paying tribute to the Barbary pirates,
the same ones who had enslaved the
Icelandic people and all that. They were
paying them tribute to just leave our
vessels alone, all right? It was and and
the Muslims took it. It's jizya, it's
tribute.
>> When America broke away from Britain,
America was no longer covered by that
jizya, they're enemies now. And the
Muslims, when they got wind of that,
started attacking American vessels in
the right around 1780s, okay? I have
never even heard of that. Oh, well, it
gets better. So embarrassed.
>> No, no, it's Well, no, it you shouldn't
be embarrassed. This system doesn't want
you to know this. That's why you haven't
heard it, okay? So,
um they start enslaving American
soldiers or sailors and torturing them
and and engaging in a lot of horrific
things, okay? And then finally, Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams go and meet one
of the ambassadors of Barbary, all
right? And we have the letter from for
Jefferson. He writes to Jefferson about
Jefferson writes a meeting to Congress.
I have it in my book, the full letter.
And he says, "Okay, we we told him, we
said, you know, we consider everyone our
friend, you know, why can't we just have
trade and get along? What did we do to
you?"
And and and Jefferson writes, "And the
ambassador told us that it is in their
Quran that they must wage war and wait
in ambush and enslave all who reject the
authority of Allah, etc. etc. And what
And the way Thomas Jefferson wrote that,
in my mind, he's paraphrasing Quran 9:5,
which I told you the sword verse, which
literally says, "Wait in ambush for
them, enslave them, and attack them."
So, that's what the ambassador told him.
And of course, Thomas Jefferson, this
great enlightened paragon, doesn't
understand this backwards Islamic jihad
stuff. Okay, so it's so so to him, it's
so weird. But it's just I just find it
remarkable
>> weird, not cuz I'm super enlightened,
but I just find it like unthinkable. So,
from the very start, you have Muslims
preaching jihad, saying that it's
because of jihad, it's because we have
to war on them. And they did war, they
conquered three quarters of Europe, so
Christian Europe at the time, or the
Christian world, it had five major
centers, five C's. One is Rome. The
other four were all in the East. It was
Alexandria and Antioch, Jerusalem, and
later Constantinople. All four got
swallowed up. And we don't hear about
that. I'll give you an example of what
the academics teach. There's a famous
professor, I used to go to Georgetown
University, his name is John Esposito.
And back in the day, you know, early
2000, this guy was like the don. You
know, the
intelligent community would go to him
for information about Islam, etc. He has
a book called Islam: The Straight Path,
and I've quoted this so many times that
I've memorized it, all right? He He
writes this.
"Five centuries of peaceful coexistence
between Muslims and Christians elapsed
before an imperial papal power play led
to a series of so-called holy wars that
have left the legacy of enduring
mistrust." So, what he's saying is that
from the dawn of
>> Christians broke the contract.
>> dawn of Islam up until the first crusade
in 1095, okay? Uh you know, that period
where Muslims conquered three quarters
>> [laughter]
>> Yes. I'm sorry.
>> and No, no, and tortured and killed and
burned churches. He calls that peaceful
coexistence.
Until the first crusade. And while we're
at it, the first crusade, again, the big
lie nobody tells you is right before it
I've already explained to you you know
what was happening. But right before it
was a really new iteration. Was the
Seljuk Turks. And what they were doing
to Christians was horrific. Okay? They
were I mean, we can get into the graphic
details. But there was always pilgrims
from Europe going to the Holy Land.
And they would rape them. And they would
murder them and cut their pull their
intestines out. And they would burn
churches and and this. And if you look
at what they called the why Pope Urban
called the First Crusade, that's what he
says. He talks about that. But they
don't tell you again that. They make it
sound like oh yeah, it was some colonial
venture
to go attack poor brown Muslims who
never did anything to harm anyone. That
is the narrative.
>> Yeah, I know.
>> it's funny.
I was on Piers Morgan right after Bondi.
By the way, then you've got that one
Muslim guy that takes down the other two
Muslims.
>> Mhm. So
and then it's like I could kiss I don't
need to do THAT GUY'S GOFUNDME.
>> [laughter]
>> I'M LIKE oh my god.
It's it's it's very hard to hold in your
head obviously cuz we love to just make
things as people you know, black and
white. It's good. It's bad.
>> Yeah. The nuances is a very a tough
place to live. So we end up in this
conversation and I'm saying well, I I
think what's happening is it's the kind
of the radicals which now I know you
don't like, but that's how I was kind of
perceiving it and Mhm. anyway, Wajahat
Ali
uh who's who's Muslim
>> Mhm.
is like oh, you're a white nationalist.
I'm like you know, I'm Arab, right? Like
just to be clear. Like is that I guess
is that is that a white nationalist?
>> Arab? I'm Arab.
>> How are you Arab? Lebanese and Syrian
and and
yeah. I'm
and and 33% Austrian or I'm sorry,
Russian Jew.
>> So you're a kinswoman. Okay.
I'm Arab.
>> Yeah, yeah. So long story short, I reach
out to him on DM. I'm like listen, I
don't you know, cuz they're like oh,
there's no percentage of Islam that's
radical. That's not true. These are
false statistics. This is a narrative
that that that that you guys have used
us white nationalist to go after us poor
brown Muslims. And I said to him, "I'm
going to post it in in this freaking I
go listen, I don't understand what
you're talking about. These numbers that
I pulled, this is from the Biden
administration's intelligence agencies.
They I like go to come and explain to me
what do you mean? I genuinely want to
hear your side. I want to know what am I
getting wrong? How am I you know at the
promoting prejudice against you?"
Never responded.
>> [laughter]
>> Never. I'm like tell me what I got
wrong. I'm here for it. I want to get it
right. I want to give you an audience to
shame me on my show because I I don't
want to screw it up. And I meant every
word of it. Never answered.
Well, what does that tell you?
Right. [laughter]
That they never answer. They will not
come on. It is impossible
to get them to come on.
And it's Cenk Uygur may but you know
he's he's come on for for other things.
He he may but it
with Okay, so so now
here's really where we are.
Um
is it too late for Europe?
And
what's what's concerning you over the
next 20 years? What needs to happen?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's very
interesting question I which I've been
actually asked a lot about and been
thinking a lot about and I'm
people they call me Denethor.
I don't know if you're familiar with
Lord of the Rings. Denethor is this
character. He's a king and he's like he
gives up and says,
>> [laughter]
>> "We're all going to die. Go go kill
yourself." you know? Because I sounded
pessimistic. But
yeah, yeah, but what I wanted what I
wanted people because I I hate when
people are just overly optimistic. Oh
yeah, we got this. We'll figure it out.
No, man. Times Times running out, all
right? And here's what's going on.
So you have in Europe you have countries
who nipped it in the bud, okay? Hungary,
Poland, Czech Czechoslovakia. You know
what they said? We don't want Muslim
migrants. And they were out front they
were open about it especially Hungary.
He said he actually he actually invoked
the logic I'm giving." He said, "We've
lived under their Islamic rule. We were
conquered by the Ottomans for 150 years.
We know what it's like, and no, thanks."
Okay, so that was his logic, and he's He
was so demonized for it. He's so hated
for it, you know.
>> would have been like, "Oh, you're a
Muslim Oh, Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Oh. Oh, so
he he's like he's like a dirty word in
Europe. Oh, he's a horrible. But
Now, look at it. He said this He did
this like 10 years ago when the migrant
crisis was at
at its peak. And of course, Western
Europe and the EU were like, "No, no,
no, we're going to take in as many as we
can, etc. etc." Now, here's the problem.
If you know anything, if you look at
Western Europe, especially, wherever you
have large Muslim groups, you have a lot
of criminality. You have a lot of
problems. And you have segregation. You
have ghettoization. You have the host
society The the the natives are afraid
to go out. The women are afraid to be
raped. And we've heard this now
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's It's going
on all the time, right? And now Now,
here's the problem.
A lot of thing A lot of these Western
European countries talk like, "Well,
we're going to get tough on immigration.
We're going to stop it." And what they
don't seem to understand is you can stop
it today, you still have a problem
because you've got like anywhere from 8
to 12% Muslim population who are
outbreeding you.
So So, for example, according to a Pew
poll, in Germany,
by 2050, that's less than uh 25 years,
okay? Uh by 2050 without any more
migration, they expect Muslims to be
like over 20%.
Okay? So, what what what will be in
2075? What will be, you know, in in
2100, okay? Same thing for France and
the UK. Um so, I don't think people
understand that it's, you know, it's
>> is terrifying.
>> Oh, it Because you aren't allowed to say
anything.
>> Exactly. Because the the government is
enabling and supporting and the Muslims
are shutting you down.
>> Like that's the part where
you know, the you've got like
Muslims in the street, you know, bring
down the West, and all of this all of
this anti-
>> Brit
>> waving of a British flag, and he gets
attacked by the police.
The police go and take him to jail for a
Facebook post.
>> saw a video of a woman a walking her
dog, British woman, but it's a Muslim
community, and the police stopped her
and forcibly moved her out because
Muslims don't like dogs.
There is a hysterical
post that went viral
of a British guy talking about how
I think it was Japan. He's like,
"Imagine if we went to Japan, and it was
like, 'We're going to need you to change
out all this sushi for, you know,
bangers and mash.' No, you won't. You
won't do that. What do you mean you're
not going to do? And we're going to need
you to pay for our housing and our
health care." And it sounds so absurd.
>> Everything here is a little bit too
Chinese. All the restaurants and cafes
and that, for a start, way too many
noodles. I don't eat eat pie and mash,
ham, egg, and chips. I mean, you need to
cater to me, yeah?
No? I don't think you understand. I'm
not from here, okay? I left the UK
because I didn't like it, all right? So,
I need you to change everything to make
it feel like it's the UK, yeah?
Still no, is it? All right. Okay. Well,
also, I can't really work at the minute.
Anxiety.
So,
when do I get my money? Obviously, got a
few kids at home, and also, they're
they're going to need to come here.
That's a no-brainer.
Um
Why do you keep saying no? I've noticed
as well, there's a lot of Chinese people
here as well, isn't it? So, I was
thinking we could get loads of me over
here, and we have our own little area,
and then you lot can just fuck off. Does
that sound good?
It doesn't. Well, no, hear me out cuz I
was thinking if we get loads of me over
here, then we can vote in, you know, one
of me to be in charge, and then we can
all start telling you lot how to live.
And after that, I was going to organize
some marches where we go through the
streets chanting anti-Chinese
sentiments. So, obviously, you'll need
to protect us while we do that. That's a
no as well, is it? Oh. And finally, I am
here legally. Um yeah, didn't respect
the rules on that one. So, do I just
choose any hotel or have you got certain
prison? I'm glad you bring this up
because this is really going to show you
how desensitized Western people have
been incrementally conditioned because
everything that the West goes through,
and I've said this before, what you're
describing, if you try to imagine this
in any other civilization, it's
mind-goblin mind- boggling. And the
reason is because why is it even a even
a
woke person in the West will find what
you said weird. Like, of course,
Americans can't go tell the Japanese to
give them
But for some reason, they're convinced
it's their job to do that to everybody.
To just lay down prostate, and I have to
suppress my culture, my heritage, my
religion to appease you. It's very
interesting because they So, on the one
hand, instinctively, if they look at any
other culture, they'll agree. They'll
say, "Yeah, that's crazy. Like, what How
how Why are Chinese people going to
you know, Turkey, and
they've risen to the top, and they've
made the Turks you know, suppress them?
It would be weird. It would be like,
that's colonization."
Yeah.
>> when it's happening right under their
nose, it's like, "Oh, no, this is we're
we're celebrating multiculturalism."
>> Cuz it's racist. That's the problem.
It's racist. But it's not racist for
anyone else.
>> No, no, no. It It like when white people
do it, it's imperialism.
And okay. So so
last question, cuz I could I I you've
written 12 books and
dozens and dozens of articles, and you
have an incredible YouTube channel and I
want everyone to go check all of that
out, but
>> What do we do?
Um, you know, I'm trying to I'm trying
to kind of it's it's scary.
Sorry, before we get to the what do we
do,
are you afraid? And I ask you this
because like I remember Charlie Hebdo in
Paris where the cartoonists kind of made
fun of Muhammad and they came in there
Yeah. and killed 12 people. I remember
The Satanic Verses and what happened uh
to Salman Rushdie.
Um
I'm stabbed, not to death, but like like
wrote a book about it I think called
lost his eye uh called knife. I mean,
even doing these podcasts, I'm like, oh
man. Mhm.
You know, my wife lived in Kuwait and
she's like, I really babe, please stop
talking about it. I'm like, well, I'm no
one to talk about it compared to
everyone else who is so if they go on
this, they're going to go after you.
>> Yeah, I know.
>> [laughter]
>> They're going to go after you know,
Brigitte Gabriel. Like, are you scared?
I think I'm desensitized at this point.
I I you know, I kind of fell into this.
I actually had a I started off like an
academic who was involved in this from a
his from a very historical point of
view, and then I just fell into it due
to circumstances cuz it all happened in
9/11. And then I was at Georgetown
University which was a leading, you
know, university with dealing with Arab
and Islamic studies. Then I was at the
Library of Congress. So, I sort of come
from a very sort of professional
academic background and my face was out
in the open. I had no problem with it.
And then but then I [laughter] started,
you know, the more I delved and the more
I spoke, the more I was saying what
people didn't want. You'd be surprised
if you go back to 2007, I was on CNN, I
was on Uh-huh. you know, NPR, like all
these places. But then, you know, they
my message you know, wasn't uh But
they've taken money from Qatar, though.
Yeah, yeah.
>> They have. [clears throat] Yeah. So,
that got cut out. Um, but at this point,
I mean, it's just I think it's an
important thing to be said. It This is a
very civilizational existential moment.
And um, you know, one person's life is
not enough to just stop it all.
What do we do? I'm watching this, what
do I do?
Well, this is a good start. You're
you're you're you're you're we're
talking about this. I always say, look,
you know, before actions you have to
have the proper paradigm in your head.
Informed
>> Yeah, so that's why my mission is mostly
what we're doing right now, which is
because I still know a lot of people
don't get it. Okay?
>> Oh, no. Yeah, obviously the majority,
right? So, we're still in this you know,
learning phase.
I believe if everyone gets it or at
least a majority, then it will all fall
into place. I'll give you an example.
You know, you're familiar with these
Sharia hearings. Yes.
>> Okay, which is I think it's good. On the
one hand it's good because you know,
people are becoming critical and they're
saying, you know, okay, Islam's okay,
but you can't have this Sharia.
Okay, that's a good step and I'm glad
that's happening. But what people are
going to eventually learn as we progress
is guess what? Sharia and Islam are
inexplicable or are inseparable. Yeah.
So, if you So, I see someone like Greg
Greg Abbott, Texas governor, saying
like, Sharia has no place here in in
Texas. And I've seen Bush say things,
well, in my mind when I in a Muslim's
mind, what you're saying is Islam has no
place here.
>> [laughter]
>> Because there is no Islam without
Sharia. Right.
>> So, you know, hopefully as you know,
people learn more and more and they
connect the dots, you start
understanding, well, you know, maybe
Islam isn't just a religion, maybe it's
a political ideology which is in
conflict with the Constitution.
>> cuz I am a firm believer. Like I am a
classic liberal in that. Like I don't
care who you pray to. I don't
>> Libertarian. I
Right. I don't care who you love. No. I
don't care that is you.
Peace be upon you. This is how I would
be like, [laughter] oh, I relate to
that. To you your religion, to me mine.
Your way of life, me mine. Like all of
that I'm like, yeah, dig it. Yes. And
then,
you know, the later Muhammad, I'm like,
no. Oh my god, no. So, it it would be so
antithetical for me to say like, I don't
want you being Muslim in my country.
Yeah. I just
the assimilation
the anti-West, the subjugation of the
infidel
>> you the Muslim is forbidden from
assimilating. I mean, it's it's already
hard enough for people to assimilate who
are from a different culture, you know?
But in Islam, it's and this is what I'm
saying, Muhammad took tribalism and
deified it. It's no longer just It's
hard enough to get a tribal, you know,
person to become Westernized,
right? But imagine in his mind it's also
a part of my religion, I can't I can't
become Westernized. I have to hate these
people.
This is what makes this really
insurmountable and what makes really
Islam distinctive amongst other cultures
and religions.
Raymond
I could I could literally keep you
probably for 2 days. Where Okay, you
have
I think 12 books and and and a freaking
YouTube channel. Uh where do people
start with your content? How do they
learn more because there's there's a lot
to know, obviously.
>> Yeah. Um I have several books and I I I
I would start actually with the more
recent The three that people I I call
them in my trilogy, it's my last three
books, which are Sword and Scimitar, 14
Centuries of War Between Islam and the
West, and that really covers what we've
been talking about, the long It really
shows you
Forget about doctrine. I spend like a
short intro about doctrine and his and
and the Quran. But then I say, "Okay, so
let's see what happened." And lo and
behold, history is one long
manifestation of the doctrine. So, it is
a real thing.
Then but I have other books like
Defenders of the West, which talks about
actual how European men fought back, uh
which is and I A lot of young guys get
inspired by that because they've been
taught to just be doormats, especially
if they're Christians. My job is to just
fall down and let everyone, you know,
wipe their feet on me.
And I have a new My newest book, which
came out just 2 months ago, is it's
called The Two Swords of Christ, and it
deals with the military orders, the
Templars and the Hospitallers. okay?
Yeah. And uh my YouTube
channel, yeah, please visit that. Thanks
for mentioning it. I think it's just my
name, but the logo is the Holy War
channel, because that's what I talk
about, jihad and crusades. And I have a
Substack as well. Uh where Yeah, yeah.
Finally, I got to it. It's great. Yeah,
yeah. Okay, I'll I'll link to it, guys.
>> Thank you. And um yeah, all those are I
I social media have things and they're
on my website, RaymondIbrahim.com, but
I'm not a very
social media active guy, but I try, you
know.
I
Okay. I'm definitely subscribing to the
Substack. Uh I think I'm going to start
on Sword and Scimitar.
>> Yeah, that that's the best one to start
with, actually. It's the first one and
it's the most It'll give you really uh
the like panoramic view of what happened
between the West and Islam. Is this
whole concept of, you know, you give
your life and in the afterlife, there's
a bunch of virgins, is that real or is
that It's real. It's in the Quran.
>> Yeah, 72 virgins. Um
>> It's in the Quran.
>> It's No, no, in the Okay, in the Quran,
the virgins are mentioned, they're
called the houris, and they're described
as basically supernatural women,
big-bosomed, and uh their name comes
from their very like dark iris, black
eyes and whatnot, houris. And um they
are created for the express purpose of
the sexual gratification of Allah's
favorites, his martyrs. And uh and and
Okay, so now then the hadith gets into
the gory details, which is or graphic
details, which is the sex is amazing and
uh you your penis never goes flag and
all you do is copulate with these
beautiful women and um
>> That's in this book?
>> It's not in the Quran, it's in the
hadith, but it's considered canonical.
It's It's considered part of the the
literature. So, yeah. Okay, so the
hadith is a separate book? The hadith is
The hadith means the like narrations
of people who heard Muhammad say this.
Oh, like the prophets kind of a thing.
>> Yeah, yeah, it's but it's it's the
secondary uh book to the Quran. It's
called They're called the twin pillars
of Islam. So, how do we know what we do?
Well, the Quran and the Hadith. And then
from the Hadith you get what's called
the Sunnah, which means the example,
okay? But anyway, all that is and and,
you know, even though you you get to
devirginize them, but then the hymen
grows back, so you can do it again.
I mean, I I I know this sounds absurd,
but it's in the books and Muslims talk
about it.
And that doesn't mean they all believe
it, like we said, or you know, but I
mean, it's in their books. I cannot
thank you enough. You're wonderful.
>> having me, Julie. I appreciate it. Yeah,
yeah. Bring back
the fire.
Bring back the
Bring back
the fire
and the
righteousness.